now to some breaking news overseas while
russian troops continue to mass near the
ukrainian border russia's foreign
minister is now declaring there will be
no war but he warned that moscow will
defend its interest in a call last night
with the president of ukraine president
biden reaffirmed america's readiness to
respond decisively if russia does invade
holly williams is in ukraine
a source tells cbs news that on that
phone call with president biden
yesterday ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski asked the u.s to tone down its
rhetoric about an imminent invasion now
that may sound strange because after all
it's ukraine that has roughly a hundred
thousand russian troops sitting on its
border but actually the ukrainian
government has consistently been urging
calm seemingly because it knows that
panic people clearing out supermarket
shelves people fleeing the country would
be extremely destabilizing as you can
see things here look very normal and
that's perhaps also because ukrainians
have been living with russian aggression
for years including a war in eastern
ukraine against russian-backed
separatists that's claimed more than 14
000 lives according to the ukrainian
government but this place the maidan the
square that is the symbolic heart of
kiev is a reminder of just how fragile
ukraine is because it's caught in a tug
of war between the west and russia we
were here almost exactly eight years ago
when there were mass protests against
the country's then president who was
pro-russian now things turned violent
state security forces opened fire and it
ended up with dead bodies on the
pavement very close to this spot now
different countries have different
assessments of what russia might do and
there's no question that ukraine
perceives the threat but the ukrainian
government seems to be trying to avoid
panicking this country and it's roughly
45 million people for cbs mornings holly
williams kiev ukraine